i have a picture of my head of a place
i don't know if it's real
[Music]
but it has a feeling and the feeling's
real my love
hi dad i wanted to talk to you about my
graduation i'm gonna be there in the
bleachers i'm gonna see you in your
let me let me how about i call you back
taking the day off in here your boss
wants to see you
i got a whiskey double you're real
sorry i want to show you something
really cool
you see all these people outside they're
not real
this is a malaysia
you ready
there's my guy welcome home this place
is overwhelming
dr isabelle clemens pioneered brain box
simulations
ugly simulated worlds to generate
appreciation for the real world
why am i not remembering any of this
don't worry about it
here we go most people say ignorance is
please
but i say you have to experience the
good
[Music]
you appreciate that
you know the other way around exactly
i'm glad i caught you word on the street
there have been problems with isabella's
research
i'm a little disoriented you're my guy
dad graduation i did not forget it's
been a crazy few days i graduated two
weeks ago
ignore her she's not real she feels real
i'm scared your head's not on straight
it's almost like a trick being played
great this is really bad so how do we
fix it
one of these days you're going to have
to choose
between these worlds
it's amazing how easy
humans can get used to even something
spectacular
you